in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 4th, on which we commemorate,
our Holy Father Andrew, Archbishop of Crete.
On the 4th of the month, we celebrate the memory
of our Holy Father Andrew of Jerusalem, Archbishop of Crete.
Our Holy Father Andrew was born in Damascus in about the year 660.
He, whom they called the most harmonious of Melodists, was dumb during the first seven years of his life.
Healed of this infirmity by Holy Communion, he displayed exceptional talents from that time 4th,
and particular in the art of eloquence on the study of Holy Scripture.
His parents consecrated him to the service of the Basilica of the Resurrection in Jerusalem,
and Theodore, the Locum Tenens, of the patriarchal throne, made Andrew his spiritual son.
He discerned in him qualities that made him wish to prepare Andrew to be his successor,
and, despite his youth, appointed him notarios to the Patriarchate,
with responsibility for all the ecclesiastical affairs of the Church.
It was in this capacity that after the 6th Holy Ecumenical Council,
in about the year 685, Andrew was sent to Constantinople with two Holy Elders
to present his Church's confession of faith to the Emperor and the Patriarch,
showing its support for the condemnation of the monotheolite heresy.
When the two Elders returned to Palestine, Saint Andrew remained in the capital,
finding the conditions more favorable for prayer, study, and the apostolic activities for which God had prepared him.
He led a retired life for some time, but his lamp was not able to remain hidden under a bushel,
and his heavenly conduct and the force of his words exerted for the salvation of souls rapidly became known to the Emperor and the Patriarch,
and he was ordained deacon to serve in the Great Church.
He was given responsibility for the Saint Paul orphanage and the hospice for the poor,
situated in the Evgenios Quarter.
For 20 years, he showed unflagging zeal in the direction of these benevolent institutions,
which he enlarged and transformed into havens of salvation,
thanks to his exhortations to repentance and the practice of the virtues.
He succeeded so well in this task that between 692 and 713 he was consecrated archbishop of Crete.
Before he could take possession of his sea, however, when he was still in the capital,
Philly Pecos, seizing the throne-deposed Patriarch Cyrus and put John VI in his place,
giving him the mission of annulling the decisions of the 6th Ecumenical Council,
and of reviving the monophilite heresy.
Under pressure from the authorities Saint Andrew subscribed to this change,
but as soon as Philly Pecos was removed from power in 713,
he retracted and clearly and openly confessed the true faith in the two wills of Christ.
He is especially known as the author of the Great Canon,
which is sung every year during the Great Fast,
and which has not ceased throughout the centuries to arouse the faithful to salutary tears of repentance.
In this great hymn, for which he has justly received the title Mistagog of Repentance,
the Holy Bishop evokes all the figures of the old and new testaments
who can serve as models in the path of conversion and repentance.
For the penitent, who at the beginning of the Great Fast recognizes himself in Adam,
seated before the gates of paradise,
the examples drawn from Holy Scripture lead him to realize
that having recapitulated the sins of the whole world in his own life,
it is through tears, askees and prayer,
but he must await deliverance by Christ, the Savior of the world.
Besides the activities of preacher and melladist,
Saint Andrew restored churches and monasteries
and founded a church dedicated to the Mother of God of Black or Nay
in memory of the illustrious church in Constantinople.
He also organized a hospice for the old, sick, and indigent,
to which he gave not only financial resources,
but also his time visiting it frequently,
tending the sick with his own hands and providing all its inhabitants
with heavenly consolation through his words.
During one of the frequent incursions by the Arabs on the island of Crete,
the Holy Hierarch, having taken refuge with his people in the fortress,
succeeded in vanquishing the enemy simply by his prayer,
and many of them perished as they scattered.
On other occasions, he delivered the island from drought by the flowing of his tears,
and held back in epidemic by becoming the physician of all through his prayer and vigils.
Making himself all things to all men, in imitation of Christ,
he had nevertheless to leave his diocese and go to Constantinople.
Friend of Christ that he was, he edified the people there by his orthodox teaching,
concerning the veneration of the holy icons, at that time threatened by Emperor Leo III.
For warned by God of his approaching end, he gathered together his friends and told them
that his diocese would not see him alive again.
Shortly afterwards, he left for Crete, and it was during a stop at the island of Mitalini,
that he found rest on the 4th of July in the year 740.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.